manifestation artistique cet après midi
place du trocadéro à paris
quelques jeunes gens dont les membres
d'un groupe de rock américain ce sont
vous voyez déshabiller afin de protester
contre la diminution de la couche
d'ozone
ils ont caché la partie la plus intime
de leur individu avec une pancarte
portant le logo lakers ternie surnom de
claude de cette première journée
d'action avant d'être emmené par les
policiers au commissariat le plus proche
et puis cette image insolite des
dizaines de personnes ont ainsi
manifesté à vélo nu pour revendiquer des
villes plus humaine et habitable avec
notamment des transports moins polluants
au total 54 villes participent à ce
mouvement mondial c'est que les journées
commencent tôt en allemagne 7 heures du
matin il est vrai que le soldeur promet
d'habiller gratis pour environ 2000
francs
les 50 premières personnes qui se
présentent dans le plus simple appareil
j'ai pas d'argent je suis étudiant
logeant profit devant le magasin pendant
qu'on attendait l'ouverture l'ambiance
était super cool on s'est même inscrit
des numéros sur le corps pour éviter la
bousculade se vendent ce jeune homme qui
porte le numéro un
le bio c'est de la folie les clients
sont plus nombreux que prévu et se passe
à 100 candidats 50 élus autrement dit un
dixième des clients repart à billets
pour l'été au frais de la princesse et
9/10 restant en sont réduits à passer à
la caisse après avoir acheté le minimum
histoire de ne pas risquer le ridicule
en retournant dans la rue